Jetzt ist es bald soweit. Am Freitag startet die Europameisterschaft 2024. Da gibt es viel Sportliches zuzusagen, aber ja auch viel zur Organisation, zu diesem Turnier und auch zu den Kosten dieses Turniers. Und weil dazu mehrere gute Recherchen erschienen sind, unter anderem im Deutschlandfunk und vom Korrektiv, habe ich jetzt zwei Gäste hier. Genau vom Deutschlandfunk, Matthias Friebe und vom Korrektiv, Stella Hesch. Und jetzt hier im Rasenfunk, los geht's. Ein bisschen lahmbarer dieser Applaus damals bei der Verkündung, dass Deutschland die EM bekommt, aber es wird eben nicht ganz so hochgepresst wie bei FIFA-WMs. Das muss man dann doch sagen und damit Hallo und herzlich willkommen hier im Rasenfunk. Mein Name ist Max Jakob Ost und ich freue mich sehr, dass Matthias Friebe hier ist, der diesen Ton auch schon öfter gehört hat. Denn ich glaube, ich habe ihn sogar in deinem Stück da was gehört. Hallo Matthias. Also gerade noch, dass sie ein bisschen geklatscht und sich umarmt haben, oder?
Ich meine, die Argumentation, Matthias, wird natürlich sein, die großen Stadien, sie stehen nun mal in diesen Städten, deswegen konnten wir nicht anders.
Ja, das gehört natürlich zur ehrlichen Debatte auch dazu, wenn man sich mal die Karte der ostdeutschen Bundesländer anguckt. Also mir würden jetzt noch drei einfallen, die zumindest einigermaßen groß sind. Rostock, Magdeburg und Dresden, die liegen so ungefähr bei 30.000 Plätzen. Aber das reicht eben noch nicht für eine Europameisterschaft. Da hätte man dann deutlich mehr investieren müssen, ausbauen müssen, wo auch immer das möglich ist, vielleicht auch was Neues bauen. Dann haben wir noch eine ganz andere Debatte. Dann sind wir auch bei all ganz anderen Kosten. Das gehört zur Ehrlichkeit der Debatte ja auch dazu. Aber klar, vier Stadien NRW hätte man auch diverser verteilen können in Deutschland. Es gäbe ja auch in anderen Regionen noch Stadien, die die Größe haben. Aber es gibt ja auch Städte wie Kaiserslautern beispielsweise, die das möglicherweise auch gar nicht sich nochmal leisten wollten oder konnten mit einer Europameisterschaft jetzt. Also ja, das sind politische Fragen, die man im Vorfeld oder die man, wenn man irgendwann sich nochmal um ein großes Turnier bewerben sollte, was, glaube ich, in den Sternen steht, auf jeden Fall im Vorfeld mit bedenken sollte.
Und wäre es deiner Meinung nach dann möglich, dass es ein Turnier gäbe, von dem alle profitieren könnten?
Ich glaube, ehrlich gesagt nein. Am Ende wirst du niemals mit allen etwas haben, wo alle von profitieren. Es hängt natürlich auch viel von den Rahmenbedingungen und dem Gastgeber ab. Wir haben bei jedem großen Turnier, kann man schon die Uhr nachstellen, die Debatte, wie wäre es eigentlich mit einem Turnier ohne FIFA oder ohne Uefa? Diese Gedankenspiele machen wir relativ regelmäßig. Auch das stößt an seine Grenzen. Wenn sich natürlich die großen Fußballverbände zusammentun würden und sagen würden, so jetzt machen wir es auf eigene Faust und liebe Uefa, wir spielen nicht mehr bei euch mit. Ohne England, ohne Frankreich, ohne Deutschland, ohne Holland macht eine Europameisterschaft jetzt auch nicht so wirklich viel Sinn. Aber das ist absolute Spekulation und dazu wird es nicht kommen, weil auch die Uefa es schafft. Wir sehen es ja auch gerade im Vereinsfußball beim Thema Super League, die Verbände schon sehr, sehr eng an sich zu binden und da auch Abhängigkeiten zu schaffen. Ich sehe es nicht ehrlich gesagt, dass das ohne Uefa oder FIFA geht.
Und mit ihnen geht es eben dann nur zu den Rahmenbedingungen, in die wir alle uns ja reingelesen haben. Danke nochmal für diese 190 Seiten. Also ich werde alles verlinken. Sowohl dein Stück im Deutschlandfunk, Matthias, eure Recherche, Stella, den Spiegelartikel, den ich erwähnt habe. Und dann könnt ihr Hörerinnen und Hörer gerne euch auch nochmal selbst einlesen. Ich bin sehr gespannt auf euer Feedback zu dieser Sendung. Denn so ein bisschen, es ist alles so, wie man es erwarten kann und trotzdem dann in den Details nochmal interessant. Sich das nochmal einfach vor Augen zu führen. Einmal bevor das Turnier startet, bevor wir dann zu Recht ja auch auf sportliche blicken. Das fand ich jetzt eben sehr schön. Und dann bin ich aber auch gespannt, wie wir in einem Jahr zurückblicken werden. Was das gebracht hat und ob die hohen Erwartungen, die werden ja sowieso nicht erfüllt werden können. Matthias hat ja schon ausgeführt, wie viel projiziert wird. Aber wie viele davon enttäuscht wurden und ob man vielleicht manches davon hätte vermeiden können. Also gerade diese Unterscheidung Ostdeutschland, Westdeutschland, die ist für Menschen, mit denen ich gesprochen habe, die eben in Rostock und woanders wohnen, für die ist das ein sehr großes Thema, dass die mal wieder nur zugucken im Grunde bei diesem Turnier. Und das lese ich ansonsten aber nirgendwo und fällt mir als im München Lebender natürlich auch nicht immer auf. Deswegen wollte ich es hier aber nochmal thematisieren. Also ich danke euch beiden sehr herzlich. Vielen Dank an Stella Hesch. Ich wünsche dir ganz wunderbare vier ruhige Wochen, in denen du alleine Bahn fahren kannst. Du kannst alleine im Park Bücher lesen. Ich empfehle da den 14. Juli abends. Da kannst du dir was richtig Schönes vornehmen. Da wird es nicht so viel Konkurrenz geben. Also ich bin sehr gespannt, wie dein Turnier sein wird.
Kann ja auch entschleunigend sein, in meinem Fall dann.
Aber wirklich.
Bist du dir sicher, dass man in Berlin alleine Bahn fahren kann? Oder habe ich jetzt einfach nur den Zynismus in der Stimme überhört?
Nee, du hast recht. Ich habe da von meinen Dorferfahrungen aus gedacht, wo es wirklich dann so war bei den großen Turnieren, da waren die Straßen leer gefegt. Aber das kannst du machen, Stella. Du kannst dann auf ansonsten viel befahrenen Plätzen, da bist du mal ein bisschen mehr für dich. Also vielen Dank, dass du hier mit dabei warst im Rasenfunk. Danke dir. Und ganz herzlichen Dank an Matthias Friebe. Wenn alles gut geht, dann hören wir uns vielleicht nochmal hier im Rasenfunk. Du wirst viel unterwegs sein. Ich hoffe ja, wir sehen uns dann auch, wenn das bei mir mit der Akkreditierung klappt. Ja, ich komme noch nicht rein. Aber ja, also Matthias, vielen Dank, dass du mit dabei warst. Und ihr könnt natürlich den Deutschlandfunk hören, aber auch natürlich die Podcasts vom Deutschlandfunk abonnieren. Sportgespräch und so weiter findet ihr alle auch in den Links. Oder da hört ihr dann auch Matthias. Danke dir für deine Zeit, Matthias. Mir ebenso. Und dann danke ich auch euch, lieben Hörerinnen und Hörern. Alles hier ist von euch finanziert, auch diese Sendung hier. Deswegen herzlichen Dank dafür. Und in dieser Sendung möchte ich mich bedanken bei Lukas, bei Mike F., bei Halloween, Amsel, bei Jascha und bei Gospod. Sie alle sind auf rasenfunk.de/supportersclubgegangen und haben uns dort unterstützt. Geht auf verschiedene Wegen, informiert euch dort gerne. Und abonniert sehr gerne den Rasenfunk Nationalteams Feed, denn da werden alle sonstigen sportlichen Sendungen zur EM erscheinen. Bleibt gesund, bis bald hier wieder im Rasfunk.
Wir geben nun zurück in die angeschlossenen Funkhäuser.